how's it going guys just wanted to make
a quick video talking about a few things
about programming that i think are sort
of overlooked or not understood well and
these are a little
tricky to get right
when you're a new coder when you're just
learning how to program and you're
getting into stuff one of the things
that you tend to think i'm getting this
because i thought this
you think that people that
like are not afraid of putting
themselves out there and doing youtube
and making videos about coding you think
that they're really good coders and the
truth is they're not if you go look at
my earliest videos and then my latest
you'll see that i've improved a lot but
that doesn't mean i know everything or
have all the answers or i know why one
language is better than the other or
anything like that like you can google
that stuff and that's
probably where i'm getting most of my
answers from like i get asked things on
especially when i'm like live streaming
coding i get to ask questions like what
do you think of rust or what do you
think of this or what do you think of
that i feel like i'm obligated to come
up with something but like not almost 90
of the time or more the answer is i
don't know why would you think i know i
i don't have the answer to everything i
guess that's the point and and you
shouldn't expect just because that uh
you know people make videos about things
they're doing that they have answers to
everything i i don't understand why
people want my opinion on rust i've used
rust for about a total of 15 minutes to
just learn the syntax and some of the
basics of how it works just uh
you know so that when i look over code i
can generally tell what it's doing
that's my experience with rust i don't
know anything else about rust literally
15 minutes that's all i've spent with
rust and people are asking me my opinion
about it i i don't care why would i care
about rust i don't use it i don't have a
need for it uh if i ever need it i'll
dive into it more
same thing with c sharp all right
same thing with every other language i
specifically use c plus plus i i really
don't care too much about other
languages and it's not that i don't like
them i have nothing against other people
who use them if you want to use python
go for it if you can get your work done
with python cool all right
but does that mean that everybody should
switch to python or that you need to
make comparisons for days and days about
why or it's better than this or that
you can find those answers pretty
quickly with just doing some google
searches and you know understanding
some of like maybe how the language is
built and stuff
you don't really need to go that far
into that stuff you basically just need
to pick one to specialize so that you
can do what you actually want to do
what it comes down to is
well we all have our own stories granted
but for me
the entire reason i wanted to learn how
to program was so that i could design
and create my own stuff i'm a creative
person i've always been that way i just
love writing stuff and coming up with
stuff and making original things and
that's why i became a programmer because
i wanted to create things not because i
wanted to
analyze languages or figure out which
one was most efficient or whatever i
just kind of got hooked on c plus
because i liked what it could do and i
liked how versatile it was and i didn't
really see a need to switch to any other
ones because well it seemed like the
other ones could do it too but i just
didn't feel like learning a new one
basically because i was already starting
to get used to this one so in order to
be creative i just kind of stuck with
what i already knew and i don't really
have an opinion about other languages
well there's this interesting thing
where um and i've been through this
phase
it's usually when you're learning the
syntax
at some point you just want to write
code you don't even care what you're
writing you just kind of want to get
practice you just want to program you
get in this mindset where you just love
programming what are you doing with the
programming you can practice all day you
can go practice algorithms you can go to
like leak code and stuff just to write
code but at some point that gets really
boring because you don't really have a
goal that's been my experience at least
so what it ends up happening is you need
some sort of project to work on and it
almost doesn't matter what the project
is it just has to be something you're
actually interested in and it becomes
not about writing the code but about
solving problems to
accomplish what you want to accomplish
so programming is more about problem
solving than anything else and i would
say that uh
that's the big reason that this is not
for everyone some people aren't very
good at logically
solving things i've just always had the
mindset where i like to walk through
things and build up to solving problems
and i think that's why i
tend to
like programming in general is because i
think it's a fun way to solve problems i
like reasoning through the code and
understanding what it's doing and that's
always just been something that's been
fun to me
some people think that coders make a lot
of money and
you can
but there's a lot of programmers and
coders that don't make any money because
it's not always easy to monetize i don't
know if you've ever heard the
term ceiling and floor i'm kind of
thinking magic the gathering usually
like if you look at a new magic card for
example and magic's a game that
programmers often like because they're
essentially little programmed cards or
execution of something sort of like a
function uh you often think ceiling and
floor like the ceiling is what's the
best it can do and the floor is what's
the worst it can do and sometimes if you
look at a car and you say well sometimes
this car does absolutely nothing it's
just like a useless card that's the
floor that's pretty bad and that in the
best case scenario what does it do and
this is sort of like it's kind of like
that with with making
making bank or making pay with coding
too the floor is still nothing you can
be really good coder but not have any
job or not make any software that
actually sells you can still you know
you can be the best coder in the world
to make no money
so there's still a business aspect to it
you need to uh either get a job where
you can put your coding skills to use
for a company uh which can be a little
tricky especially
that's a whole nother subject i would
say overall if you're trying really hard
to get a job you'll probably get one
pretty quickly because
employers tend to like people that are
highly motivated and ready to go and if
you show that they'll hire you but if
you're kind of lazy and you're just like
always waiting for orders players tend
not to like that because they feel like
they're wasting their money like they
they just find themselves asking
themselves like why do they even hire
this person he doesn't get anything done
i don't it doesn't matter how good you
are if you don't actually get things
done
so that's kind of the thing for making
pay you can you can be a really good
coder but the floor is still zero if you
don't actually
knock stuff out and monetize it somehow
and maybe that needs its own little
video i'm there a lot out there about
how to monetize coding and there
you can come up with them if you just
like ask yourself the question and write
down a list you'll have beat every video
about the subject because they're all
very obvious it's like make apps make
videos make tutorials you know it's
stuff like that it's it's all very
obvious stuff for the most part there
might be some like really creative ways
to go about it too you know there but
for the most part it's just making
content or getting a job where you're
making content for someone else and
sometimes that content is uh working on
some behind the scenes code for a
company where no one really ever sees
your code except the other employees
there it's still
in a way content i guess i'll just say
that the ceiling for programming is
really really high i think that's what
people mean like if you make something
that ends up doing really well you can
make millions of dollars sure
but it's it's not always easy and it
requires some luck because okay uh
here's the thing that i think is really
interesting almost every piece of
software is exactly the same take a step
back i know they're all designed
differently use different technologies
you do use different stacks but they all
literally do the same thing it's crazy
when you think about it so
one day my brother was visiting and he
was asking me about soft we were kind of
talking about
my program he was asking me some
questions about things i would mention
an app and he would say what does that
do and i found found myself answering
that question with the exact same answer
no matter what the app was it's like
okay what does twitter do allows people
to
uh
send messages and upload video and um
stuff like like that what does instagram
do same thing what does uh youtube do
same thing what does facebook do same
thing like wait are there any apps that
do anything other than that that are
successful no pretty much no all apps do
that it's like media you can upload
media you can connect with people that's
what every successful app does it kind
of blows my mind after a while it's like
all right what about snapchat was the
big deal with snapchat same thing
uh oh okay all right what about tock
what's the deal with tick same thing
exact same thing
why do we even need all these apps you
literally only need one to just do these
things and that's it yeah you you name
an app dive into what it actually does a
little bit forget the code stack forget
about how it does it just look at the
end result and you'll see that they're
basically all the same where does that
leave you
so
so
for me to just make another app that
lets you upload media and talk to people
yet again it just feels like a useless
app because that's what everything
already does now uh you might be saying
well what about
you know there there's other stuff
there's like trading apps and
stuff like that too but any you know all
social media apps essentially do the
same thing they just make like one
little niche like oh we don't save your
data it deletes and the other ones are
like we save everything
i don't know pick your poison um geez
that's a weird topic all right well
that's it for this video let me know if
you have questions and i'll i'll do a
part two of of uh
things that coders probably don't know
that are actually pretty obvious or
whatever i'm gonna end up titling this
video hope you enjoyed this entertaining
video or my attempt at making an
entertaining video rather that's always
a weird thing too i never know if a
video is actually going to do well until
i
put it out sometimes i think oh this is
a great idea i'll make the video let's
get a million views it's like 10 views
and then i'll make another one where
it's just like oh this is the dumbest
video ever i guess i'll just upload it
and it does really well
you just never know that's that's
another thing about these type of
processes is uh yeah you have no idea if
it's gonna actually resonate with people
so let me know by smashing and hitting
buttons and stuff and if you want to go
further there are links down below to
support me thanks guys peace
[Music]